depuis vendredi neymar est au coeur
rouler on vous l'a dit d'un scandale
sexuel accusé de viol d'affaires s'est
énormément de riz au brésil et en france
il ya des retombées incroyable même le
président du brésil mari qui s'est
exprimé sur cette affaire
c'est un truc de fou tous les jours il
ya des rebondissements et neymar serait
au plus mal et aujourd'hui il ya de
nouvelles révélations je voulais lee qui
fait encore la une de la presse on vous
a préparé une vidéo récapitulative et
juste après on aura isabella isabella
c'est une journaliste brésilienne elle
est la référence en ce qui concerne le
football brésilien en france
elle suit neymar depuis son arrivée au
psg en août 2017
elle sait tout sur neymar à
l'interviewer neymar de nombreuses
reprises elle connaît également
rafa est là qu est la soeur de neymar
vous allez voir
elle va tout nous raconter parce qu'elle
connaît voilà elle connaît bien le
dossier et vous allez nous dire ce qu on
a pensé le président brésilien puisque
même lui s'est exprimé sur cette affaire
et il ya même la sélection brésilienne
qui a demandé à neymar de ne pas jouer
en sélection brésilienne pour le moment
vous voyez tout cela a joué depuis le 31
mai dernier et le plainte déposée à
l'encontre de neymar par une jeune femme
brésilienne qu'il accuse de viol quinze
jours plus tôt à paris rien ne va plus
pour le numéro 10 si dans un premier
temps tout semblait sous contrôle suite
à sa vidéo plutôt bien reçue par
l'opinion publique et aux avocats de la
jeune femme qui avait décidé de ne plus
la représenter à cause de ces versions
trop changeantes depuis 24 heures le
vent semble tourner pour la star du psg
en effet francisco nos veneto le vice
président de la fédération de foot
brésilienne a fait savoir ses
inquiétudes quant à la qualification de
neymar pour la copa america selon lui
une vidéo compromettante pourrait sortir
dans les prochains jours ce qui
fragiliserait beaucoup le joueur pour
son père qui est également son manager
pas question de laisser planer le doute
plus longtemps son fils n'est pas un
violeur et cette histoire est un piège
monté de toutes pièces pour extorquer de
l'argent à neymar derniers
rebondissements dans la sphère selon les
médias brésiliens la plaignante ne se
serait pas rendu par deux fois aux
convocations de la police pour être
entendu ce soir sur notre plateau il
avait la paglia riz journaliste sportif
et spécialiste de neymar était avec nous
pour nous aider à comprendre les dessous
de cette affaire
6 merci d'être avec nous ils avaient là
alors isabella vous vous suivez neymar
depuis des années pourquoi neymar pro
vous avez choisi de suivre neymar vous
étiez fan de lui vous avez tout de suite
senti un potentiel incroyable
en fait j'habite à paris depuis cinq ans
et depuis qu'il est arrivé au psg je
fais des interviews avec lui parce que
ma chaîne des droits de la champion's
league
donc on a beaucoup d'axés pour faire
interview tout ça ça mais depuis qu'il
est à s'auto ce que j'étais encore au
brésil
j'ai suivi les débuts de sa carrière ben
c'est exactement alors cette affaire
tout moment par hervé mathoux
mine de rien franchement c'est un truc
de fou ce qui se passe parce que tous
les jours il ya des rebondissements là
dessus est ce que vous vous intéressez
vous à 7 à fait à ce que oui bien sûr
mais bien sûr parce que c'est ça des ca
des conséquences sportives est évidente
il ya copa america donc l'équivalent de
championnat d'europe est sud américain
qui va débuter dans quelques jours donc
il ya sept suspense est-ce qu'il va
jouer ou pas jouer parce qu'il paraît
que le sélectionneur brésilien lui a
demandé donc pas jouer non non non c'est
l'extrême qui joue présentement qu'à dix
déclarent qu'ils jouent les sportifs ont
envie qui joue yassa ya des conséquences
bien sûr éventuel pour le paris saint
germain puis a pris à la sphère
juridique c'est pas du tout exprimé sur
cette langue j'ai même vu un article
est-ce que voilà vous pensez qu'ils ont
raison pas du tout s'exprimer c'est
étrange silence assourdissant par un
cristiano ronaldo a eu le même genre de
problèmes et fait l'objet de même genre
d'accusations la juventus sans trop se
mouiller parce que dans une affaire
comme ça vous n'avez pas intérêt non
plus à vous mouiller en a dit en tout
cas cristiano ronaldo le joueur qu'on
connaît en tout cas il est correct et
c'est le pg pour l'instant ne reste rien
on se dit mon lit qui disent alors 2
dans les deux cas elle pourra lire une
grosse bêtise si c'est vrai aussi semblé
nos pages il a rien dit je vais arrêter
prudent il m'avait répondu des infos si
j'avais des dernières infos alors sur
déjà sur la jeune fille avant sur la
jeune fille cherche et le président vous
disais tout à l'heure que la présidence
a exprimé ce soir il ya eu des résidents
brésilien extraordinaire pour dire il
traverse nema un moment difficile mais
je le crois
neymar ce soir je suis avec toi ce soir
je devrais aller au match du brésil
contre le qatar j'espère pouvoir prendre
démarre dans mes bras et avant la
rencontre ça c'est ce que dit le
président brésilien ce soir après ce
qu'on a appris aussi c'est que la jeune
femme qui a porté plainte pour vol ne
s'est pas présenté à deux convocations
et lundi et mardi alors qu'on ne peut
pas mener dans quatre si elle ne peut
pas ne s'en rend pas les contredire on
les a convoqués encore mercredi
on verra effectivement alors ce que ça
donne il ya une énorme inquiétude du
côté du clan neymar puisqu'il est une
vidéo compromettante du joueur qui
serait sur le point d'être diffusé
c'est le père de neymar qu'il explique à
la télévision brésilienne
regardes quoi on perd ce n'est pas le
cas et il paie sa vie qui commercialise
les imagine d'avenir où l'on met un
terme à des films à 6,6 des faits d un
péno mais je te dise que l'on permettait
aux clients
alors oui sur cette vidéo justement
l'entourage de neymar est en train
d'expliquer avant même qu'elles ne
paraissent puisque même le vice
président a commencé à évoquer cette île
cette vidéo qui va sortir
il semblerait que quand ils arrivent
dans la chambre le deuxième journée marc
se rendent compte client est un
téléphone qui est en route qui est en
train de le filmer et là il faire il
perd le les plus huppés pète les plombs
en disant mais qu'est ce que tu vas te
faire tu veux me piéger et là
s'ensuit une sorte d' altercation entre
eux c'est donc chacun peut l'interpréter
comme il l'entend cette altercation en
fonction de là où ça va être coupée
montée et visionner donc le clan des
mardis attention c'est elle qui au
départ a essayé de piéger et voilà pour
ce faire vous voyez des images de nous
on est mardi que s'il y avait il y avait
le téléphone n'était pas assez pour
filmer et qu'elle se serait jeté sur lui
sur quel gâchis
quel désastre quand même pour neymar ont
tendance à lui en tant que footballeur
quand il fait juste la une des tabloïds
et des princesses et super triste en ce
moment oui mais enfin ça fait longtemps
déjà il a déjà perdu son brassard de
capitaine
mais ce qui s'est mal comporté au stade
de france avec un supporters et donc on
a voulu innover sans son brassard de
capitaine
moi je trouve que c'est super dommage il
avait là est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette affaire vous qui le
connaissez bien bon déjà je connais marc
parent foot c'est ça il lui avec moi
elle était toujours respectueux très
gentil bien éduqué de rencontrer c'est
un amour soit exactement mais après
c'est vrai qui tous les choses qu'on
parle en ce moment c'est hors foot de
neymar il doit et répondent sur les
terrains il ya beaucoup ce prix baissent
préparés pour jouer la cofam
eca parce que c'est très important après
après la coupe du monde ratée et j'y
crois qu'ils lui il a envie de jouer la
copa america mais les débats c est ce
qu'ils savent à avoir des problèmes pour
les groupes parce qu'imaginez futur le
sélectionneur l'a donnée aux comptes de
presse 27 questions ils vont 3 cinéma
c'est normal alors est ce que vous savez
dans quel état il est actuellement en
ema il est hyper triste et préoccupé on
voit qu'il est un peu tête comme ça et
je sais qu'il tout son entourage ils
sont très préoccupés parce que c'est
déjà un âne et hyper dieu pour lui
mes blessures les polémiques des
carnavals et a perdu les brassards les
problèmes au stade de france
il a c'est lé moment de remettre en
place de ces vrais maîtres de jouer au
foot des répondent présents
mais louis hyper triste il est un peu
mou et en ce moment et partage sur les
réseaux sociaux des passages de la bible
se voit là et il devrait faire ça parce
que c'est il ya beaucoup de choses au
brésil
ces commandes nouvelles à un série
soleil jour on suit ça si c'est jusqu'à
lors d'autres choses de polémiques
d'aider à voir que ça peut avoir des
conséquences très lourdes pour lui
notamment financières puisque né mars à
lui tout seul
c'est un énorme business 1 voilà on
s'est regardés on vous a fait un petit
récap quand on est l'un des joueurs les
mieux payés au monde et qu'on est suivi
par 100 millions d'abonnés sur instagram
on représente forcément un important
business et avec les ennuis qui entoure
aujourd'hui neymar suite elle plainte
pour viol son empire économique pourrait
en pâtir de son côté nike sponsor
officiel du joueur a fait savoir dans un
communiqué que pour eux la situation
était préoccupante
nous sommes profondément préoccupés par
ces accusations et nous continuerons à
suivre de près l'évolution de la
situation un contrat qui représente
plusieurs millions d'euros chaque année
et que neymar a signé jusqu'en 2022
du côté des produits dérivés neymar
venait également de lancer un parfum
avec la marque diesel
neymar devait également se retrouver sur
la jaquette de la nouvelle édition du
célèbre jeu de football fifa ea games
les concepteurs du jeu pourrait prendre
la décision de l'écarter des visuels si
cette histoire venait à prendre trop
d'ampleur autant de questions en suspens
et une affaire qui pourrait au final
coûter très cher au numéro 10 brésilien
isabelle à la dernière question comment
elle voit la presse brésilienne et
l'opinion brésilienne voix se voit cette
histoire comment le public brésilien
voit cet historique qui sont pour les
bah oui ils sont contre lui il faut
savoir qui la portent plainte de la
fille la tombe est justement de la
finale de champion's league
tout le monde était en train de regarder
au brésil et après qu'il situe à a
dévoilé les porte plainte
on a parlé quai des cadets 20 mars a
fait une semaine presque qui on parle il
sera sûrement les brésiliens ou pas
comment il est soutenu par le peuple
brésilien va au début et tout le monde
était assis un violeur et tout et quand
il a fait la vidéo parce que tout le
monde désire mais bon neymar jusqu'à
présent peut-être qu'il n'a pas commis
un crime mais la conel a dévoilé la
conversation même s'il cache l'image de
la fille ça c'est un crime et son père
dans un émission brésil a dit je préfère
un crime d'internet qui est un crime de
viol donc neymar était perdons dans tous
les cas il a choisi ou hyper moment ce
qui va comme cyril oui enfin c'est que
on a tous c'est ce type de joueurs sont
des cibles
ouais c'est évident qu'on a tous comme
ça l'impression qu'il est tombé dans un
piège et qui voit là mais après il faut
respecter sa présomption d'innocence
comme il faut respecter
versez le potentiel avant la petite le
potentiel que la femme soit victime
voilà il ya une enquête
l'anc est à mon avis ça assez simple à
mener pour qu'il ya bien sûr beaucoup
d'éléments notamment matériels donc
voilà il faut rester là c'est la france
de se caresser
là il a bien résumé la situation de quoi
tourner tout le vide conclut une enquête
en tout cas ils avaient là je voudrais
vous remercier d'avoir été avec nous on
vous retrouve tous les samedis à 22
heures dans l'émission europe 1 sport
pour les restes à béton
[Applaudissements]